hi I'm Hilary Duff and I met BuzzFeed
I'm here to do an interview no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't answer questions when there's
puppies do you plan on writing any more
books in the future and what are you
reading nowadays I don't I don't have
any plans to write any books it was one
of the hardest things I've ever done and
right now I just finished a book called
pachinko which I loved
it was very ambitious for me it was like
five of these pages and now I'm reading
a book called I see you look at this
sloppy body
what's one childhood teenage experience
you feel like you missed out on I never
got to have braces and I never got to
have a locker it's two things I really
was desperate for would you ever do a
Lizzie McGuire reboot honestly the idea
sounded terrible like two years ago when
we when reboots were happening but you
never know I don't know I love I love
Lizzie McGuire and it might be really
fun to see where she is now hey get Adam
a fishbowl do you still know the
monologue from the locker room scene in
a Cinderella story is it like something
about waiting for you is like waiting
for the rain and a drought
scene little like memes that's why I
know if you could have one normal day to
yourself without any paparazzi or fans
what would you do I'd probably go to the
beach and I would just be with my kid
we're so used to it now but it is not
the fans of paparazzi kind of a crab as
a bum-out so that would be nice to just
have a day where he's not aware and I'm
not aware and mean which tries to
probably go about into normal stuff are
you team Josh or team Charles and why
I'm team Josh always team Josh once
Charles and Liza finally bone and get it
over with like what are they gonna still
gonna talk about books all day I wish
that you guys could watch this and like
get the smells as like additional
sensations it's so cute
did you or anyone else ever get hit with
the giant red falls in the Lizzie
McGuire opening credits scene yes all
day long giant red balls just flying at
you at what moment did you realize you
were actually famous oh I know the exact
moment Lizzie McGuire aired and that
weekend I went to go meet my friends at
the mall and I literally had to hide in
a janitor's closet it was like the
craziest thing
I had to call my mom from the plot like
someone who worked at the mall was like
getting me in a closet and my mom had to
come and pick me up it was really crazy
it was actually a little scary yeah this
tiny little nook is so fun ste you and
your little heart is just pounding
you're so cute if you had to give your
younger cast members yearbook super what
is superlative guys didn't go to high
school like what's that Nico would be
the biggest flirt for sure
Miriam would be the class clown I think
probably Kelsie would be like prom queen
did I do them enough okay
which one of your songs could you listen
to on repeat if you had to and which one
would you want to erase from your memory
my boyfriend brought it up the other day
he was like you know what's a bad song
wake up wake up with the back song it
was so cute like you know that one from
the newer album I loved spark the single
it was really fun there's a lot on
metamorphosis that I wish I could forget
but then so many people come up to me
they're like everything to me and they
always call out the most embarrassing
someone it's like there's a song called
the mask and I don't get it at all
that's like one of my most embarrassing
moments in life so probably a lot from
that record hard to choose really what
is your favorite Lizzie McGuire episode
and which episode haunts you to this day
my favorite episode is I want to bra a
bra bra bra bra first of all I think
filming it was absolutely mortifying for
me excite probably had just gone abroad
in real life anyway but when I watch it
back I might
it's so funny what if this all went to
[ __ ] and I started getting like beat up
off by the puppies this is like the best
thing ever I think everybody she gets to
play with puppies no matter what their
job this is so happy this is so funny
honestly this is the best treat ever
guys all of these puppies are for
adoption through the North Shore Animal
League America who wouldn't want to play
with this all day get your puppies oh my
god this is the best
[Music]